Let's discuss Key Based Routing. First, we'll talk
about the greedy approach. What I'm showing you here
is the state of the routing table at
the source node, which is fourteen. And the key
that I'm looking for, let's say is four,
and therefore in the greedy approach, I would assume
that The key K, that is K being four, will be stored at a destination whose node
ID is four. And what this table is
showing, is the routing table at the source, and
in particular, the entry that you have here,
where you have a valid entry, those are the
nodes that are reachable from. Node fourteen. So
from the source node fourteen I know how to
reach node number thirteen, I know how to
reach node number three, I know how to reach
node number two, zero and five. I don't know yet how to reach node number four
because that is not in my routing table at this point of time. The intuition
in the greedy approach is if I'm looking for a particular key, K, in this case,
K is 4, then I know that the node that is likely to have that key,
K, in this case 4, is going to be the node whose ID is also 4 and so this
is my desired destination, but what I'm going to do
in the greedy approach is get as close to the
desired destination in the node_id namespace. If I look at
the state of my routing table, I don't know how
to get to 4, which is my desired destination, but
I know how to get to 5 which is close
to The desired destination in the name space of the
node ID's, so what I am going to do, is
ask this guy, because I know how to reach him,
and he is close to my desired destination, do you
have a way of getting to destination number 4? And
my hope is that he may know the route to
get me to the desired destination, and I'll be done.
And getting the key value pair that I'm looking for.
That's the idea in greedy routing. Take the minimum number of hops to get to
the desired destination by using information that
is available in my user level routing table,
that has information about which are the
nodes that are reachable from me directly. So
the objective in the greedy approach to routing
is reaching the destination with the fewest number
of hops. That's the key. So in other words I am optimizing my own look up. This
"me first" approach we know can lead to congestion
and particularly the tree saturation that I mentioned earlier.